c'est sympa mais le sanglier you to
death et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur far cry 3 pour une petite
vidéo en live délire alors bon vous avez
déjà sûrement vu les vies des vidéos
pardon de far cry 3 bon je vous
expliquais vite fait quelques trucs du
jeu histoire sassou pas ce qu'ont déjà
vu des tests ou quoi précis où des
review de fou malade ou quoi parce que
je pense que c'est le cas pour pas mal
de gens vu que far cry 2 est un jeu très
très très attendu et qui a très très
très très plus à moi le premier
d'ailleurs
alors c'est parti alors écoutez j'ai
fini le jeu c'est à dire que bas que le
mode
bon il n'ya plus de missions à faire
mais je ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
parce qu'il ya plus de missions à faire
que j'ai fini entièrement le jeu pour
autant il reste quand même beaucoup de
choses à faire notamment je veux montrer
sur la carte à capturer des avants
postes donc tous ces petits drapeaux
rouges la cedeao peu sa capture et à
aller enlever le brouillard cassure des
antennes notamment sur les autres donc
les antennes qui sont rouges c'est celle
que je n'ai pas fait donc en a plein ici
là toute cette petite zone là je
faudrait que je fasse donc c'est qu'on
va l affaire juste après en attendant on
va essayer de chasser du sanglier à
l'arc
parce que j'en ai besoin de enfin j'ai
besoin de peau de sanglier pour
confectionner une cartouchière une
cartouchière qui me servir à apporter
beaucoup plus de munitions parce que je
dois être le seul mec à avoir fini
farcry sans avoir même confectionné le
plat première cartouche r c'est à dire
qu'en fait pour chaque item donc ici on
peut voir ses quatre buts un
portefeuille etc
vous en avez plusieurs donc vous faites
le premier donc la flèche est pas une
peau de chèvre par exemple pour en
débloquer le premier que vous permet de
porter deux armes
je les fais ensuite life aline peau de
chez pas d'ours par exemple pour porter
trois armes je les fais hélas dépôt de
requins pour pouvoir porter quatre âmes
je les fais aussi il se trouve que
cartouchière il faut juste de pouce
onglet pour débloquer premier et je
l'ait pas fait alors on actuellement
dans une zone où il ya du sanglier
j'aimerais bien en trouver
alors attendez mais c'est très simple
plus précis on sait vers ici apparemment
ce qu'on a de quoi fabriquer un instinct
de survie confection ludique chasse
instinct de chasseur âgé pas ça permet
de voir en fait les animaux eux cros map
littéralement bon alors qu'ottawa essaie
de monter un peu plus haut là bas là
alors là est-ce que j'en aurai un dc si
j'en ai un dc attention non
non haïti chap ok sont juste là bas
alors attention faut pas que je tombe de
trop sinon je risque de mourir
on y va en eburnie bah tu perdu la
moitié de ma vie en une minute chutent
faut que je fasse attention ils sont
vérifiés sont vérifiés sont vers ici et
ils sont là non c'est un tigre [ __ ]
merde on va pas aller faire le kéké à
côté un tigre j'en attends tu as un
coucou bordel [ __ ] beach vient là
c'est bon on a eu deux alors on devrait
avoir tout ce qu'il faut on va supprimer
vite fait dans le sac à butten supprimer
toutes ces choses qui ne servent à rien
rim involontaire alors je supprime je
supprime supprime je supprime je suis
prêt mais voilà on va avoir des poussins
sangliers voilà moi y'a plus l'animation
ont joué comme vous montrez animations
voilà vous voilà alors maintenant on va
pouvoir confectionner ça tout de suite
bon c'est aux personnes que je vous
montre vite fait au moins comment ça
marche
on va confectionner la première
cartouche hier ensuite il nous faut une
peau de buffle et bat fuck
on va pas aller là faire c'est le super
content on va tout simplement à l'aide
du voyage rapide donc en fait far cry
pour ce j'explique vite fait c'est une
île d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que c'est
que cette icône sur nakisa vous pouvez
me dire unités de test alors nos
analyses c'est une île sur laquelle on
se retrouve en fait on était en vacances
avec nos amis et on est tombé sur des
pirates qui nous ont pété le cul à coups
de machette et de la fiche de paie
thomas moore vendre bien cher bande de
blanc et on a réussi à s'échapper on
voulait sauver nos alliés c'est ce qu'on
a cherché à faire pendant tout le jeu
avec deux jolis fin on avait un choix
pour finir je mens je vais pas vous
spoiler mais c'était vraiment un choix
assez foule soit on était pris voir bref
je ne dis rien
et au final donc on a capturé plein
avant postes s'est tous ces petits
icônes jaune et noir là que vous voyez
les flèches les avant postes qu'on a
capturé les drapeaux l'asse les avant
postes qu'on n'a pas capturer qu'on doit
capturer et à quoi vous sert tout
simplement les avant postes il vous
servent à faire ça
c'est à dire à vous déplacer ultra
rapidement across the hill et c'est
honnêtement ça sert beaucoup puisque
chaque région de lille et spécifiques à
certaines espèces donc par exemple à des
régions de l'île où il ya des sangliers
voilà par exemple on a du cochon là on a
du lourd cela on a de la fièvre on a ou
la journée du chien qui court vite chez
plus l'union la du cerf on a tout ça
tout ça on a du rouquin fin bref c'est
voilà ses goules et donc ça me permet de
vous téléporter across the hill
alors on va tout simplement attaqué un
avant poste on va essayer de la faire en
mode discrétion et à kingston en poste
c'est parti alors prendre la munition
hockey niveau arme qu'est ce que j'ai là
ça ça on va se la faire discrétion
snipers ah oui [ __ ] j'ai quand même
bien plus de balles que juste avant on
va voler de la thune aux mecs une
dollars c'est le prix d'un mac donald
allez hop c'est parti et ce curé une
petite voiture par hasard non non ok bon
dortoir faire à pied non c'est bon wada
a je suis en zone ennemie d'accord ok
chances de l'ennemi enfin la jouer
non ok ok ok on va se la faire à la boue
rend les gens non aux jo bo au nom mais
[ __ ] mais c'est quoi ces deux ennemis
de ouf là ok alors toi par contre bon je
tue lequel toi ok ça c'est fait next 20
mai ils vont venir à combien là
tiens tiens oh là là [ __ ] mais c'est
la guerre d'entrée de vidéos là ok ok
bon on va vite se barrer d'ici non non
je trouve une touche [ __ ] mais ils
sont sérieux vas-y vite monte monte mes
potes à l'est sont mortes dégage dégage
dégage [ __ ] mais son sérieux les gens
mais tu es un métis tu veux que je fasse
quoi bon j'ai une petite idée a priori
de soi à faire boum
ok mickeal ça c'est la grosse galles la
1e guerre les gens me dire attends up
ok bon du coup je fais péter toutes les
voitures bonsoir on va se barrer
moi je m'arrête il en reste une juste là
c'est bon bon du coup j'ai un peu pété
tout mais mun ce qui va pas nous aider
pour capturer la banque
enfin bon alors danemark rennes vous
propose donc
donc en dehors d'une exploration libre
la com sont en train de faire bon tant
que j'ai pas capturer tous les ans au
poste de croisé pas mal d'années surtout
dans cette zone c'était la dernière zone
dans laquelle on s'est retrouvés avant
de faire le choix final de la fin du jeu
bref la dernière mission en vidéo ici
c'est pour ça que d'avoir beaucoup
d'ennemis voilà donc il me repère direct
je suis plus qu'à boucler ou quoi que ce
soit ça par contre c'est une zone
ennemie et j'arrive comme un gros google
[ __ ] non vite couper l'alarmé la larme
non ah ah ok ok alors c'est absolument
pas ça que je vais vous montrer le côté
moral
quick scope tarn et avaient déjà parce
que je suis là haut
c'est bon j'ai actuellement c'est-à-dire
qu'ils pourront pas appelé en force et
elle frappe ailleurs en plus des knicks
qui a déjà donné son sérieux à toi tu
vas pas me refaire son coût de tout à
l'heure à dégage je vais devoir me il
sauf que j'ai plus de deux strophes
104,30 be fully matin est chaude et qui
va arriver vite vite vite vite vite
[ __ ] merde tout un arrêt aurait
justement dans la merde jeu typiquement
dans la merde
ces quatre mots match up 10 arrivent de
partout jusque là j'aurais tente
bédouine et c'est bon je veux aussi
soigné bon logiquement le hockey alors
toi tu marches dans le feu non mais
[ __ ] mais merde quoi mais oh là là là
là mais daf
c'est n'importe quoi
ah mais c'est un gros bond va essayer de
la faire plus enclines à sion va tout
mais pas au japon reste à jouer comme ça
à merde j'ai loupé [ __ ] tâche et péter
la larme juste appris qu'ils étaient
désactivées je suis dégoûté
alors toi mme oh là là ben oui il va
bien sûr bien sûr alors le mec me jet
set up élèves des clous de son bras
normal comme cela en était tiens tiens
tiens tiens j'en ai marre de la jal est
là
[Musique]
ok alors c'est qui le passent maintenant
un bon alors écoutez [ __ ] j'en aurai
chier bon vous a vu ses petits mini
montage là plutôt stylée pour vous
qu'est ce que ça fait du bien bon alors
maintenant qu'on ait eu l'avant passe
juste à côté
à pau va faire la quête voix du chasseur
tireur ça c'est un truc est offert
délirer alors en fait pour chaque
avant-postes capturé on a une quête ont
donc on a deux types de quêtes on a une
quête voix du chasseur qui coûte donc
c'est une quête on a mal apprécié à
chasser avec une arme précise et on a
une quête aussi des fois où même des
fois les deux on doit tuer une cible au
couteau donc une cible désignée un
endroit que thouars lassé des léopards
donc on va devoir tuer des léopards au
lance-flammes bon ça drôle c'est parti
un petit véhicule s'il vous plaît et on
a juste ici j'ai jamais compris cela en
plus à me sucer un 4/4 simple pour
autant pour moi alors c'est parti il
veut couper comme ça comme des gros part
ou non le pont le pont va prendre le
pouls en mode sauf à être plus amusant
rapide je suis content lazare trou et
ceux à l'avant poste
olala plus ta petite action je me
retourne jean makoun lance-flammes là
bas où tout ça tout ça c'était plutôt
rigolo alors c'est parti
mec qui se garent appel en douceur buzz
ou cassent tout
le lance flammes alors là le truc c'est
qu'on est ce qu'on peut prendre
c'est des feuilles écarlate frais
comprennent des feuilles qui nous
permettait de fabriquer en fait la wii
donc disais alors et semafo ce
magnifique les serveurs sont
actuellement en maintenance dès que je
me chips a fait ça alors un style
chasseurs pour et des feuilles en bray
alors est ce qu'il y aurait moyen bon à
mon avis ils ont nommé une île sont pas
bêtes enfin il nous arrange un peu ils
ont dû mettre des feuilles pas que de
l'écarlate non plus ce serait un peu un
peu lourd
d'accord je crois au final gates que de
les gars là de bon comment je vais
retrouver ces foutus le haut par mois ab
sont là bas donc qui sont dans cette
zone marc ok alors j'ai jamais fait une
quête voix du chasseur sans avoir le
truc qui permet de voir les animaux eux
crossman bon alors empressé de choses
avant alors bon on va jeter toutes ses
feuilles de carla faut vraiment que je
rentre tout ça c'est quelque chose qui
demande ça je crois que c'est d'écarlate
aussi mon ya que des carnets il aime
bien les carrelages
alors on va faire appel à nos yeux à
notre instinct d'hommes au baba voilà et
ben voilà
sacré instinct puisqu'on va aller cramer
du léopard à coblence l'âme amené vous
ici wesh wesh wesh
neige
là bas les marques
ok donc y en a un qui a cramé o o tout
doux tout doux tout doux
bob je rigolais aaa
et de deux merde je prend feu je prend
feu et un flottant peut être un [ __ ]
que c'est bon ok alors il en reste deux
à tuer alors on va essayer de
l'approcher tout doucement comme des
vieux four de sauter beau
sur un espèce de [ __ ] avec les animaux
c'est abominable alors la propagation du
feu au parc rails juste excellente
regarder ça se propage et ça se propage
et ça se prend pas pour elle si je reste
là je vais crever ça se propage jusqu'à
moi et casse toi d'là le dernier il est
ou du coup il a juste paris mais bien
comme il faut bien loin des histoires
qu'on galère bien retrouver web radio
moi j'y crois mais une forêt je
réfléchis alors la petite nation quand
on plonge qu' il n'y a d'ailleurs pas eu
puisque je n'ai pas plongé des eaux mais
logiquement si je fais ça et puis qu'il
fait beau j'aimerais juste trouver en
fait moi [ __ ] ça a bien cramé à celle
du grammage de luxe à je suis un beauf
qui sifflent je suis un beauf qui seyait
à mais du coup mais comme on va galérer
à trouver dernier [ __ ] je m'en veux
tellement il devrait rester dans la zone
bleue collectionner la seringue
l'instinct du chasseur c'est ça ou pas
le oui lesquels voilà cher et bien
cadrer dans la zone on va pouvoir
confectionner sa confection chasse
l'instinct du chasseur
ah bah non plus j'ai pu en faire deux
attaques on se la met donc vous
l'instinct du chasseur et on devrait le
voir le crossman logiquement si tout se
passe bien
alors soit je suis aveugle soit il est
pas là va se rapprocher tâche est
toujours du mal en plus avoir la queue
c'est comme ça alors pourtant restreint
quatre jours quand même 40 secondes bon
on devrait quand même réussir à trouver
l'espèce recherché mais vous la voyez
vous non sérieux je la vois absolument
pas on devrait voir un bas la forme de
l'animal à travers la tra les roches et
ou alors est ce que peut-être qu'une
fois qu'on leur a fait peur il se barre
de la zone bleue en tout cas la masse
ringuet serbe se voit rien on est bien
d'accord ok bon je tombe d'accord
ouais et ben écoutez je crois que c'est
un gros fail
soyez un bug soit je ne le vois pas mais
là je veux voir où on va se mettre la
deuxième voie là puisque avec des petits
drogué attend plus je colle ma tête à
l'écran mais comme un gros gogol pour
essayer de trouver mais alors est-ce
qu'en mettant le feu à la forêt
peut-être que enrichira norman en moi je
crois que c'est fail c'est aussi simple
que ça quoi c'est fait ok bah voilà
super on l'a loupé
bah [ __ ] le feu à cette forêt on va se
pencher un bâtard non pas moi à merde à
ça va vite un jeu faut le feu à la forêt
mais me sentais kwata je suis dégoûté là
moi je pourrais pas vous montrer
dommage on aurait eu des jets prix qui
étaient là bas maintenant bon tant pis
on s'est bien vengé comme il faut
j'abandonne
on va se rendre aux pylônes juste là bas
pour pouvoir
alors à quoi sert d'indic qui donne
autant pour moi à ce qu'on ait une mini
map en fait la ja oui si vous regardez
la main pour ma gauche apparemment de
minima puis à rien il ya chez aucun
chemin tracé ou quoi on va devoir aller
choper et tout bon bah c'était pays ce
sera plus simple
l'actp juste là à les voir la tour
déverrouiller et on va se quitter sur ça
en tout cas far cry et une sortie mais
inattendu en fait j'avais acheté l'un
quand l'autre il ya très longtemps
ça va pas vous dire quand il ya vraiment
très très très très très longtemps et à
lui disent qu'ils étaient au vert
rouille et puis ça m'avait pas plus plus
que ce à quoi bon j'étais plus dans dans
l'époque dans mode counter strike quoi
donc j'avais pas trop pas trop patron
qui fait et au final mais alors là mais
le 3 mai alors mais c'est mes énormes et
honnêtement c'est juste du pur plaisir
de l'éclade total plus en plus il est
bas alors là graphiquement alors là on
va pas remuer le pot dans la peinture ce
qu'il veut rien dire mais j'ai rebondi
sur son beauf en ce moment honnêtement
il est juste magnifique graphiquement
c'est bobo bon là c'est loin d'être au
maximum les graphismes ou quoi je j'ai
pas un pc de faux faux faux mais bon on
fait avec ce qu'on a et e on va aller
défoncer sa mère
r également à mais à chaque fois je dois
me retaper tout ça waouh
mais vous merci bon ça va y en a moins
que tout à l'heure et heureusement pour
nous alors on va juste choper l'antenne
voilà voilà bah j'espère qu'il va y
avoir des petits ennemis sur le chemin
sainte-foy pouvoir en faire craquer avec
des cocktails molotov
c'est quoi ça les patates à durand on
peut assez de la feuille blanche qui
m'aide pas pour ramasser les feuilles
blanches et m pourrait plus chez les
patates à durand c'est pas une voiture
je dis pas non pour monter tout là haut
en plus c'est vachement bien foutu et
alors au niveau des animaux c'est
scripté c'est à dire que si vous mourez
que vous revenez les animaux seront pas
au même endroit que la fois d'avant
match et vont pas pareil etc vous pouvez
souvent voir il ya quand même un instant
entre animaux sait déjà que les animaux
se chassent donc je peux vous pouvez le
voir telle ou chassés du mouton ou des
trucs comme ça ça c'est assez fun
père parvient pas me sauver et alors du
coup je vais pas vous montrer le truc
enormissime du jeu juste maintenant un
petit plus mais un oui honnêtement far
cry vachement bien foutu on pense à
blanc beaucoup de choses dont je vous ai
pas montré ce que ça fait de se faire
chasser par un crocodile enrager c'est
le truc le plus stressant du jeu or ils
vont venir me faire chier on va monter
on va les dépenses à court terme
ok ok c'est pas par là c'est là alors on
montre juste là on leur fait les cul ça
et c'est de m'avoir c'est l'espoir alors
avec mark cuban encore jamais vu ça
un pardon call of
mais bon ben alors lui il n'y croit
qu'il est caché qu'il suffit qu'il
suffit qu elle demande malades ces gens
là avaient complètement fou bon alors on
monte à j'ai hâte de vous montrer là
vous allez vraiment adoré bon je pense
qu'on a quand même pas mal
bon je sais pas un spoiler c'est un
petit truc qu'on débloque dans la
deuxième partie du jeu puisqu'elle a
pris à partie du jeu on a que la
première il et puis ensuite on est
envoyée fuck that sur la deuxième il
faut qu au [ __ ] mais merde quoi mais
qu'est ce que c'est chiant ça des fois
baladé un fois j'ai mis dix minutes à
comprendre le la manic qu'il fallait
faire vous dire à quel point des fois on
galère quand c'est sûrement que j'ai le
qi d'une poule quelquefois mais mais
autrement c'est pas facile contrairement
à ce qu'on peut croire la voix il faut
passer pingisi up pour être pile à
[ __ ] c'est de l'autre côté d'un puck
comment on va de l'autre côté en passant
par là ouais c'est bien par la tac tac
ils sont sérieux il faut sauter là je
pense ouais
puis la tacc passe là dessus et hop faut
aller encore de l'autre crée des sites
industriels pour faire un saut périlleux
comment ça se passe
et pixels
oh [ __ ] j'en ai marre marre j'en ai
marre j'en ai marre j'en ai marre alors
c'est reparti on va remonter papas des
mamans boum boum boum boum
[ __ ] mais c'est pas possible
non mais qu'est ce que c'est rageant
alors vous n'avez pas intérêt à me faire
cher je le dis tout de suite voilà ils
vont s'arrêter puisque leurs potes sont
morts géant terra tués sous la tourelle
fait ça a cassé la sécheresse qu'une
bulle de savon à lui me fera pas chier
oh là ils vont venir me saouler bafin de
colette 6 à 6 à la fois j'ai fait une
triple saut far cry vont en mode solo
tout en s'étonnant l'histoire voilà
alors on continue à papa tac ça on l'a
déjà fait
comme ça on allait là où juste derrière
hop y avait un cordage alors les chiens
vous avez pas me saouler ça si on
pouvait pas venir jusqu'à elle a alors
sauté ici tac
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre oh là
là mais il s'arrête jamais de passer ici
c'est pas possible c'est la zone ne peux
pas tester le jeu comment ça se passe
tac où on en était on était vert ici il
fallait faire le tour tac up parfait up
parfait
c'est là je sais pas comment on peut
faire alors faut aller là-bas d'accord
peut-être comme ça tout simplement passé
sur celle ci n'est pas faisable je
suppose c'est faisable
parce que j'ai fait il ya deux logements
est tombé passé par là bas vous passez
par là faire un saut périlleux
je comprends pas
d'accord y'a rien au dessus on peut
aller que là-bas pour monter là où il ya
les cordes blanche nord-est par là ça
commence à me faire chier
oh mon dieu ah mais non mais c'est juste
là en fait
[ __ ] mais quelle débile incroyable
voilà c'est mon hop on y est tac
l'échelle kebemer quelle galère quelle
galère gogo alain va enfin pouvoir avoir
une animation sympa et puis
déverrouiller surtout la carte dans
cette zone c'est parti jll inc clic
[Musique]
elles nous montrent le périmètre qu'on
voit sur la carte maintenant ces
informations
et voilà et hop et à chaque tour à
débloquer on a une arme gratuit dans le
magasin donc par exemple 3 chez que
c'était l'arc
on a eu une casse souvent avec deux des
dollars et le truc et puis on now voilà
oh là là par exemple j'ai débloqué
l'espace 12 gratuit en magasin et
maintenant l'église nd johan je voulais
vous montrer la chose la plus belle du
jeu et vous quittez sur ça on se
retrouve un jour une prochaine vidéo
c'était la détente sur far cry j'espère
ça vous aura plu toi tu remontes pis
[Musique]
ensuite le 10 comme l'anneau dîner
tournant
je n'en attends tu dis que ça sonne faux
me situerais trottoir
fort de ma